Okay, we are live. Hello folks.
I am very late today.
Very late.
I am late because of several reasons.
One, I was just freaking tired and it
took me a while to get things going this
morning. Second of all, let's see if you
can see in the background
kind of new bench, new equipment, new
plates,
bunch of stuff got unloaded, few other
things to deal with as well.
So, as the uh the title suggests,
Man actually sees this message and
replies to help.
We will forgive the rust dev because he
makes really good stuff with it
and he's actually working to like fix
the rough edges.
Okay,
I'm going to move this over here.
And today I'm going to try to make
puffer lib less garbage
streaming
now to make puffer lies
garbage
and have set up.
Cool.
We're going to do community PRs today.
Uh, and we're going to do setup
shenanigans.
I'm just going to do this right out of
the box.
Force those build dependencies match the
version.
So, it's going to be something like
this, right?
same version of torch that is installed
in the project
environment. So, how do I
extra build dependencies?
Okay, let me let me actually just give
him the courtesy of reading the full
docs before I complain. Make sure we're
doing some reasonable stuff.
Okay, we've got Kyouung here
taking a look at this. Uh, the idea
today is we're going to make Puffer Live
less crap to install and I'm going to
merge in a bunch of uh, contributor PRs.
That's my plan for today. Today is a
chill housekeeping day
and some coffee
and some benching
on my plan for today.
I also set a new PR on this course on my
morning run was chill.
We have scripts.
Project may define guies.
Hello Kong.
We are going to fix some things today.
plan is to fix things, merge PRs, and
then play with some new toys that I just
had delivered.
Presence of a build system to determine
if a product contains a package that
should be installed in the project
virtual environment. Build system is not
defined. UV will not attempt to build or
install the project itself just as
dependencies.
Build system is defined. UV will in
build and install the project into the
project environment.
Python project must be built to be
installed.
UV.package package will force a product
to be installed into the product
environment.
I don't know what this means.
Oh, okay. So, this is true anyways.
Cool.
Project environment path
build isolation. So this is what we need
flash attention and deep speed need to
be built against the same version of
PyTorch that's installed in the project
environment.
Okay, so this is exactly what I want.
Packages may accidentally omit necessary
dependencies in their declared build
dependency list.
Augmenting the list of build
dependencies allows you to install a
package in an isolated environment but
with extra build dependencies that are
not declared in the package itself.
Yeah, I'm going to see what I can do on
this.
Well, I have this one thing merged.
I think what we do first is we go let's
go grab a vast box
AI
console
50 cents an hour 46 cents an hour yada
yada
Uh,
Park,
British Columbia, Texas. We will pay the
nice Texan man.
Oops. Log in.
Hang on. Let me go authenticate the
authentication.
Oh, okay. Okay, let's do this.
55 cents
instance created.
if there's a way I can do that
in the uh project packaging, that would
be great. Separating into multiple repos
is just going to cause me immeasurable
pain.
if I can do it in the same repo, I will
look at it.
Let me make sure that our default set
works first.
But the thing is like if you're using
puffer liib without ocean and you're
using it on slow environments
like
there's basically no reason to install
like to not have at least some ocean
environments. Like it's there's
basically no smart thing that you could
possibly be doing that doesn't involve
at least some of the ocean environments.
If that makes sense.
Like there virtually zero circumstances
where you're uh not installing Ocean and
you have a good reason to not be.
Exactly. So like, oh well, we don't need
ocean because we're just going to train
stuff on our environment. You're doing
it wrong, right?
There it goes. Just took a few seconds.
Okay.
I don't know. The other thing is just
like breaking [ __ ] into more and more
little bits. It's like it's not free to
do that. It makes a mess of your
project.
Like realistically, the correct thing to
do in my mind is just to like compress
the size of the package as much as
possible and
like make sure that ocean is not causing
problems.
Hello. Welcome.
Welcome Yogi.
Where that Fred Flintstone?
I don't freaking know.
let's just make notes on everything
that's annoying.
I'm going make some some little notes on
the side here
and I should follow the the instructions
on the website, right?
That's not a great uh intro.
Is Puffer spamming garbage
and lagging a ton
and then eventually training fast. Yeah.
Actually doesn't learn as well as it
used to.
It's a regression.
Small one, but it's just still a
regression.
Okay. What can we do to improve
on this?
So I just go get like some old cuda,
right?
Okay, cool. Now we get um absolutely
insane error, right?
Like this without the no build
isolation.
Let's read everything Charlie said
again.
this is a configuration users have to
put in their TOML.
This one is useful though. We can patch
a few things.
Yeah. Yeah, I know, Tim. It's annoying,
but it's the best thing we have at the
moment. And I'll tell you, so X has
gotten so bad um for me mentally
that
I've got this this is a $100 phone. I
got this as a temp thing cuz I broke my
old phone. Um it's actually kind of
funny how decent a $100 phone is these
days. But I ordered myself one of these.
I ordered one of these
basically just hoping that it's it's
completely impossible to scroll X on
this, right? You can download whatever
apps you want, but you're not going to
be scrolling X on a freaking Kindle. Um
cuz yeah I basically
want like
I do have to spend time on X because it
like helps more people see Puffer and
stuff but my ideal is just spend as much
time as possible on core research
problems like core science and
engineering and then on exercise and
nothing else in between. That's the
goal.
brick things.
There are a bunch of other ones that
like
they just limit your apps, but that's
not good either, right? Because if I
need to check X for business or
messages, I need to check my app. Like
just like, you know, giving me kitty
lock is just stupid, right?
This is just a different device that
essentially
it kind of circumvents the
ease and convenience that these apps are
exploiting to make them addictive in the
first place.
Okay. So this is this is the problem
right?
Compile with
no kernel image.
So, can I do
Hang on.
I don't know if this is going to be a
proper test. Did it say 12.8 or 13?
I think it did. Right.
Well, I mean, all the community stuff is
fun, right? I actually
I wish I had more time to really do like
to really build out all the community
stuff more, but like the thing is at
some point, right, I the way that my
brain works, I basically get blocks of a
couple weeks at a time where my brain is
actually working on full before I get
kind of burnt out. And whenever I get
that time, it's like I have to just
ignore everything else and work on one
of the major updates to Puff or it
doesn't get done right because like
that's basically the only time that I
can get the really hard dev chunks done.
You know, in this most recent uh recent
one, we did all of constellation and I
started on the new uh optimizations.
Before that it was the on verse off Paul
Enough.
sweeping a lot right now. So, there are
a couple things with that that we're
going to get to this week. Um, we need
the thing that actually helps a lot,
Tim, at the moment is figuring out why.
Like there are some environments that
don't have clean score or perf metrics.
We basically want every environment to
have a nice 0ero to one normalized PF
metric and it has to not like leak
memory so that it like it can't kill the
sweep basically if you run a thousand of
them. And pretty much nothing should be
leaking memory, but there are a couple
weird exceptions. And there like a
couple functions where we just haven't
bothered to implement the close function
or whatever. Huh?
It's funny that that doesn't do
anything.
Ocean Ms differ a lot in terms of
quality. Yeah,
we have at least a dozen that we've
trained on so far that have been pretty
solid. So, there's like they differ in
terms of quality along a bunch of
different axes though, right? Like some
of them it's the code quality is bad.
Some of them have like some janky bugs
in them, but the code's pretty clean.
Yeah, new Tetris sounds great.
I actually So, I found out that the
current Tetris is that it's not bad.
It's just um
Okay, this is one of the annoying things
about having this Perf metric the way
that we have it, right? Like you need
some good way to normalize it cuz it's
like a 0ero to one metric.
I could technically do like an automatic
normed score thing, but
yeah. So I guess the the question then
Tim is like
do we just delete the PF metric from
every env and then do everything based
on score? But then like I can't do that
either because even in constellation. So
in constellation I could add in an extra
normed function that's like normed per
env score or whatever but I can't do
that in like Neptune or wand
Grid is good. Grid is maze. Grid is the
uh the maze environment. I probably
should rename it, but
in Sweet Puffers optimizing score. Yeah.
No, no, it's for reporting, Tim. So,
it's if you're going to compare, if
you're going to have multiple different
M's worth of sweeps on the same plot,
you need the metric to be comparable.
Okay, so these are all lovely pietorrch
issues.
Constellation's pretty sweet though that
we have like this whole look like a
pretty sizable chunk of code for a
week's worth of dev.
I saw some there's a slime volley env.
I'm interested in getting in the
overcooked env.
I'll throw Finn at some of these. We'll
see.
tank one looks awesome. Yeah.
So, an end that we will use. It's just
like
it has to be fast and stable and have
like a reasonable metric.
I'm not a quarter as fast as you, dude.
I don't I'm not even like a fast dev,
honestly.
Nothing I do is super fast really.
Like I was always the guy that would
finish everything last in school.
I'd always have a perfect score, but it'
be last
give back.
M are fun. There's a lot of cool stuff
you can get into. Honestly, I Tim, you
can do both. like pick a fun pod project
that you think will be useful but that
you'll also learn a lot by doing.
I would say like the advice I'm going to
give you is that there's a lot of cool
stuff you can do in the range of like
5,000 to a,000 lines. Projects that get
to be over a thousand lines like these
actually start to become like mediumsiz
projects. And like I'm sure somebody's
gonna say, "Oh, a thousand lines of code
is so easy, bro. I have 50 billion lines
of code." But like a thousand lines of
actual dense code that's not just there
for no reason can do a lot of stuff.
Like constellation could be a thousand
if I refactored it nicely. The whole
dashboard.
Hello Peru.
Welcome.
I'm attempting to find stupid problems
with installations in Puffer at the
moment.
Can somebody explain to me why the hell
the optimizer has max autotune on by
default? That's awful.
Community PRs. Yes, I'm going to be
doing community PRs today. through
that is 382. Yes. Which one is this?
Uh yes, of course. This one I'm very
much interested in
as soon as I deal with uh basic install
issues and stuff.
Does this thing not have a compile mode
setting?
So, Peru, I have tried so hard to make
the install good and like Python just
like there keeps being dumb stupid
Python stuff that breaks things.
I'm working on stuff now. But at least
look, I think that honestly at this
point, aside from that one license thing
that I just merged where I was it
Kittybo, somebody sent me a PR
apparently that broke it and then I and
then another one that unbroke it. Um,
I just ran this on a fresh vast machine
and it worked. I'm going to update the
install instructions a little bit.
I'm going to update a couple things
and we're going to hopefully just make a
a couple light changes.
Okay, so now we no longer have that
garbage spam.
Um, I'm also going to change the docs
real quick.
Uh,
let's do
Can we figure out why this stupid thing
is not working here?
Like it should be showing my live
stream.
Oh, it's probably cuz I changed my name
on YouTube.
Live stream.
Is there a way that I can do if I just
click this? Is it always going to be the
same?
Do you also need trained policy to play
on the web? Um, it's preferable.
It's like, but the thing is if you just
if you're training an MLPSTM, it's
really easy. Like any of the standard
architectures are really really easy.
I think you don't need the no build
isolation anymore, Tim is the thing.
Oh, and install torch separately. I see.
You're right. You're right.
You are right. Hang on.
Oh, that's another good question
actually.
Oh, this is easy.
We can just do like this.
ID.
See if this one works.
Uh, this is the same channel idea as
before. No,
I think it's the same freaking channel
ID.
Unavailable.
It just says unavailable everything.
That's weird.
You run the sweep in my puffer m I did
run. Oh, okay. I can't find optimized
parameters in CLI and 1B.
All right, let me show you. It's a
little bit obnoxious and um the thing
that I'm working on right now is going
to make that a lot better.
This is uh so either Neptune or Wii,
it'll be basically the same thing. I
have this set up. So, I'll show you real
quick.
So, typically you end up doing something
like this. You group by system tags.
This is Let me find an N.
And we can just go to here.
We can decide what point we want from
this. I can decide. Okay, I have a whole
bunch of runs. Let me like add a filter
to this.
Come on. This is why I'm building my own
because all these freaking dashboards
are so stupid and laggy.
This is embarrassing quality of
software.
right. So, this is one item. Yay.
So, there could be multiple runs here,
you know, that fit the query. You can
check them in here if you'd like. You
know, you can go like this and then just
show the one run and make sure you like
the training curve.
and make sure that it's like a sane
Well, this one doesn't have a sane
training curve. Lovely
long.
But when you find the run that you like
the curves of,
you take a look at it in here and then
all your hypers you're going to have to
copy from. Most of them are in train,
but then there are a couple of them
sometimes in ENV and such as well. It's
annoying that this is not automatic. Um,
I don't think there's any way to make it
automatic from this viewer. The project
I'm currently working on is it's not a
full replacement for WB
because obviously I'm not just going to
casually replace
the full all the features of this. But
this new project called Constellation,
I'll show you. There's one really
awesome feature to this thing.
All right. So, here's constellation.
Uh, evidently I don't have any data on
it. Damn it. I'm on the wrong branch.
Let me see if I can get a repair real
quick.
All
right. So, this is constellation.
This is the new project. So, here I have
breakout and I have all these different
metrics and I can decide I like this
point right here. Okay. Okay. And if I
just right click this point, then what's
going to happen
is it's going to just copy all my prams
into my clipboard.
That's the nice thing I'm working on
that I hope that you'll uh enjoy. But in
the meantime, you still have to manually
copy stuff.
You showing wannabe?
Yeah, I can try wannabe.
I haven't used wannabe in a while, but
it's the same thing.
Uh if you want if you can send to me the
uh oh allow embeddings enabled in
YouTube Studio. Thank you. I'll try
that. They might have added a setting
that uh that URL used to work and the
channel ID didn't change. So it's weird.
How can I do it in a wannabe? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, uh, I have no idea
what these these runs are, but we have a
bunch of runs here. Let's go find a
metric.
Oh, I know what this is. Cool. So, let's
just go to win rate.
This is the best one right here. So,
it's this orange one. If we wanted, we
could filter it to make this easier,
right? So, we can do what is this?
filter
generate
greater than
0.2.
Yes.
Okay. So now we have far fewer runs and
it's easier to find them. And I can say,
oh, actually we like this one the most,
right?
And then we go from here, we go to
project.
Uh, I believe it was project. Hang on. I
haven't used this in a while.
Charts files. Where is it?
Yeah, there it is. Um,
Did wand break integration at some
point?
Oh, there it is. Overview.
Yeah, here it is. It's in overview. You
have all your parameters.
You go. This is these are the ranges.
Then you can go to train and you have
all your params,
right?
Get involved, man. Build some M.
It's a great way to learn.
Grab a couple buddies, jam on uh, you
know, come up with like a project that
you think you can do in like 600 to 800
lines of code at most. Jam on that for a
weekend and learn some RL stuff.
and Armen? Let me figure out allow
embeddings enabled in YouTube Studio.
Let me check my settings.
RL lab this quarter. Very good.
Get him to use Puffer Lib if they're not
already.
trying to figure out what the heck it
was that changed in here.
I go to the exact place
that shows the same hyper hypers as my
config which I use for train starting
for training.
Ah
then something might have changed. Let
me fix this one thing and I will see if
I can fix that for you.
Savannah.
Okay, I can't find this button. Can
somebody please explain to me where this
button is while I figure out these uh
hypers?
All right, let's see what's happening
with you your stuff.
This gets
updated C files. What do you need?
Well, ideally the model
so we can put it on the website.
Puffer export same as eval but use
export instead of eval. It'll dump the
bin. You stick it in resources. You set
the path to that.
It looks to me like this should work
for the web. You build it yourself. Oh,
yeah. I'll I'll take care of sticking it
on the web if you give me this PR.
if you can make sure that it's actually
like human playable nicely as well
because the current Tetris is a little
janky to play.
Let me go find my old womb API key.
Moment
and I get these values straight from my
CLI.
Um, I don't know how you would do that
because the thing is this is the problem
with using something like W to be,
right? Like it's 200 experiments. So,
yeah, technically I could have it print
out or save all the little files, but
then you're not going to be able to know
which one to actually use.
Let me go figure I'm going to go figure
out if it's a bug though or not because
I guess it's technically it's possible
that something got introduced where um
it's like getting the defaults instead
of the sweep params. I'd be kind of
surprised because I know that there are
people that use wi for sweeps
and I haven't touched it in months.
Possible something changed on the back
end though I guess. Yeah.
Neptune has been stable. So, the only
thing that the only sketchy thing about
Neptune is word on the street is that um
they're like deprecating their old thing
in favor of a new thing that's going to
be like paid only with expensive
licensing towards the end of this year.
Um,
and we might go back to wand to bee if
they do that.
If there's like no free option for
users, cuz I'm obviously not going to
have the default for puffer be a
non-free thing.
So, it's better at the moment, but it
might only be better for a while, like a
little while.
I see all this these hypers. Yeah.
And then if I do like if I just do sweep
Okay, I'll let it run one experiment and
then we'll see what it does from there.
Kind of weird.
Oh, no. because it's supposed to do the
default for the first experiment.
Yeah. So, that's a correct
that is a correct thing right there. Let
me see if it shows up correctly in my
dashboard as well.
That's weird. What? Where did my
freaking run just go?
One B.
Where's Where's my old account? This
stupid service.
That's not like the worst UI anything or
anything like that, huh?
All right,
hang on.
Okay, here we are. So, this is the first
run. Yeah,
let's just look at an arbitrary param.
So gamma is 0.904.
And then this shows up and then I click
this.
Um T are you I did write train.
Ah yeah. So that's that's not running a
sweep then.
So there are two things right you have
to actually run a sweep and then also in
parameters here you have to go under
train if you go under sweep it'll show
you the ranges right like sweep will
give you train atom min and max and
stuff the values are in train so if you
call sweep you'll get like a whole bunch
of experiments defaults like 200 200
so it looks like this is working
let me know if there are any other bugs
where where do I get the YouTube thing
from? I want to fix this stupid stream.
We can have it on the website.
but I don't know. I think it's going to
give me the embed just for the stream.
Does anybody know how we can get uh an
embed for
not just this one video?
YouTube Studio.
Hang on.
This says go to YouTube Studio
Select your current
or scheduled live stream.
Guys, did they actually like just
disable embedding your stream?
If not, I'm gonna just link the Twitch
one like if they did because that's
ridiculous.
So, apparently Twitch uh YouTube just
decided to break it for some reason.
Uh, this setting does not exist,
right? This setting does not exist.
So, I literally can't find a way to do
this, and that's kind of stupid.
Okay. So, I think I can do this instead,
right?
Hang on. We're going to get this to work
and then I'm going to go back to doing
real work.
It's crazy that like I don't understand
how it is that um any platform thinks
it's a good idea to have like five
different pages with 20 nested menus.
Like dude, if I'm having a difficult
time figuring out where stuff is on your
website, your users hate you.
sad.
Why sad?
Please check your browser console for
more.
Okay,
getting somewhere.
I love when it's like the simplest
thing. It's just nothing ever ever just
works.
Do I have to like does this do I
actually have to update this on? Um,
okay. I'm going to give this five more
minutes and then I'm going to just go
back to dev and I'm going to delete it
because this is just this is so
incredibly stupid
to be stuck doing this [ __ ]
Like it'd be nice to have an embed on
the uh the server, but if something this
simple is going to end up just being
this stupid, then screw it, right?
Someone wants to contribute to Puffer,
what types of contributions are you
looking for? If you're new and trying to
get into RL, then uh the easiest thing
to do is to follow my guide and start
building some fun environments. If
you're more experienced, there's tons of
open stuff on the research side, on the
edge side, on like just general
usability, on uh performance
optimizations. I mean, there's just
massive amounts of stuff, so you're
going to have to be a little more
specific.
Yeah. Okay. I'm sick of having the um
I'm sick of like dealing with this.
We're going to just delete it.
We're just going to delete this. That
that ends up being the solution is to
delete it because
evidently
I like I literally don't even know how
that's possible for like YouTube
embeddings generally across the board to
just stop working. But whatever.
Okay, this is fine.
Um, do we want to do
Why did you ignore my message? Yo, how's
it going, man? You just said yo, right?
And it's because it's a two character
message and then there was another one
after and I was not looking at the
screen.
Yeah, I have my X on here. The streams
are also on the X as well.
It should be like if you check uh X also
has the live indicator now, right?
Yeah, X also just has the live
indicator.
Okay. So, Charlie put the effort in to
make uh to figure this out for me. So,
let's at least let's do this
match run time. So, this you can't do,
right?
But he also sent me there was one other
thing.
Wait, where did it go?
Oh, here we have concept of conflicting
extras.
Bro, nah. This is quadratic.
This is quadratic, right?
Hang on. Is this?
I think this is going to be like a nice
to have that we're just going to I don't
want to do this until we actually just
prune a bunch of old dead packages that
nobody uses anymore
cuz we honestly we do not need to
support as many of the environments as
we still have like old bindings around
for.
What's this?
Oh, whatever.
Okay.
Does anybody else have requests around
setup, installation, general UX, things
I can fix quickly before I move on to
doing uh community PRs?
Charlie Charlie Marsh, creator of UV. He
was kind enough to uh reply to a thread
that I wrote and he gave me some good
information. So, I made that the stream
title for today.
[Laughter]
Oh, that's funny.
like honey I can find you some thousandx
engineers 100 or thousandx engineers but
they will not accept your job offer
we're going to start on PRs. Let me use
the restroom. Let me get a couple quick
sets in. I've been lazy today.
And
we have
a contribution here. This is a puffer to
only fish. Oh yeah, speaking of which,
this is only fish. You can submit a
puffer and it will show up here. You can
train puffers to do different things
like eat the stars and to play with your
cursor as well. Here, eat all these
puffer.
Okay, so we have a few environments.
We've got a few fixes.
We've got a few easy PRs to merge and a
few complicated ones.
Let me use the restroom real quick. And
we will also let me think what I want to
do.
I'm also I have not done my daily
deadlift.
Let's do that first. Deadlift set, bench
set, one accessory set, and then we
start on PRs.
or dead single rather.
Currently weighed myself in at 169 this
morning.
That is uh
195 bench for eight and
pretty easy. 355 deadlifts cold.
That's good.
One message before I start
on these
Buffer file has been PR to the correct
place.
Thank you. merged
coinfinder environment.
Let's do fixes first cuz fixes are
quick.
So, you just submitted me
a disgusting patch.
Okay, this is actually a real one. I
know this is just a harder thing to look
at.
Um,
Please do not submit or delete upper
lip.
Why were you hating on Dale Carneg's
book?
The two worst [ __ ] I know uh
were both clear cut from that playbook.
So, no. Screw it.
I don't read that type of [ __ ] man. I
don't even read anything of that. Like,
I don't read any
I literally just read fiction. Here, let
me show you something.
I'm going to show you my audible list.
Revenant files. Oops. Where is it?
recently added.
Where are they?
All
titles. There we go.
Resin files. I've been listening to
Cderon's Fury series.
Hyperion.
Oops.
Come on. Camera.
Uh, what else is on there? Oh, yeah.
Culture Series.
Uh, Aragon should be on there. Yeah,
there's Aragon.
And then Lord of the Rings.
There you go. That's my rating list.
Yeah, but if it's Welcome to America
book, that's like a welcome to America
book. How to be a shallow [ __ ]
I should actually just get in the habit
of trying out PRs instead of blind
emerging everything. Yeah. All right.
How do I do this?
I actually do not know how to do this.
Isn't that funny? That's how often I
just merge [ __ ] straight away.
Well, no wonder I haven't done this.
That's disgusting.
had a girlfriend.
Well, you think I've always been single?
Garpath has had many, many years. Uh,
I mean, what was he doing in his PhD? He
did a couple wonky things. Like, he did
this thing where he'd write all the
neural nets in JavaScript for some crazy
reason. He always had like a ton of side
projects that he'd finished some of. Um
I think his best known paper was
literally just like what happens if I
slam a comet and an LSTM together
or comment. I don't even know if it was
an LSTM. I'd just been on RNN.
Probably was an LSTM.
Uh, this looks worse than before,
doesn't it?
I mean it depends what you mean, right?
like
I mean the only person whose work I
actually know well enough to say that it
was like truly
brilliant as Costas. This
you guys are at Stanford at the same
time. Yeah. Well, um, so I
my first entry to research I interned in
Fe's lab when I was 16 with Justin
and Andre uh Andre was there at the uh
the same time.
Radford was awesome. Yeah, Radford I met
at OpenAI. He was a really great guy.
Bradford's like the type of guy that I'm
pretty sure I can't like imagine anybody
having anything bad to say about him.
He's just like a nice chill guy that was
good at like good at research.
I guess some people would say that he
was not he is not on the engineering
side at all. He'd write a bunch of stuff
from scratch and notebooks every time,
but
that's about it.
just overall swell guy
and there really not that many people I
have like all good things to say about
you know
I tend to be pretty cynical so it
actually counts when I say
Fe good. Well, you can the thing is you
can Okay, let me make this clear for
guys. You can't ever tell with
professors if you don't know them from
when they were younger because like the
only thing that you can clearly tell the
thing that's really clearly measurable
right is when somebody does great IC.
if they're no longer writing code and no
longer doing their own projects like you
have to have you have to interact with
somebody for way longer to have any idea
and even then it's not clear right
like you can say that yeah for a
professor they've had like several
brilliant students or several students
that did amazing work, right? But then
how much of that is their students and
how much of that is the professor? You
basically can't know without like
knowing the professor personally,
right? Even like more than I interacted,
right? So all my interactions with Fay
were good.
I was at like several group meetings.
This was over a decade ago. I actually I
saw her um I saw Fay a few weeks ago in
uh in SF because I went to uh I went to
go say hi to Justin at uh at World Labs
cuz I hadn't been there in like or I had
not seen him in like a decade.
I mean like literally even with my own
advisor, right? because like Philip's
background was mostly in computer vision
and like on the academic side right like
how do I position stuff for academia
like what's like the type of stuff
that's going to get academia excited he
was very very knowledgeable right but
then like if you step into the side of
things where it's like hey we just have
to do a ton of heavy engineering to
solve this problem then you step outside
of outside of expertise right and then
that comes down to how much are the
students willing to do that.
It's a lot easier. Basically, it's a lot
easier when people are just doing their
own code like and they're actually
participating on that level because it's
super easy if you are if you are
technically good. It's very easy to just
go through somebody's code and see what
they write. And it doesn't take that
much stuff. Like it takes maybe a couple
thousand lines of code of going through
stuff before you can tell at most.
Yep.
Wrong PR.
missing semester. Yeah. So, missing
semester, it's not a course. Um, so MIT
has this thing that is,
what's it called? IA
whatever they have there's like so MIT
has an unusually long gap between its
two semesters and you can take these
optional mini courses basically uh and
that one is just like hey all the
practical [ __ ] that you're supposed to
know some of it's basic some of it's
stuff you won't use some of it's good
it's like a decent enough thing to do
yeah
because like you see, as long as I don't
care about looking stupid for a second
cuz I don't know how to go check out a I
don't know how to go check out a PR
um from another like you know it like as
long as you don't look stupid care about
looking stupid for a second. Most of the
stuff's easy to figure out though there
are definitely some things that you need
to know exist right and that's useful
for that.
Okay, this is guaranteed LLM stuff, but
we'll look.
Gnome Brown. I have no had no
interactions with Nome Brown.
Never met him.
Ilia's cool.
Okay. So, this is very very similar to
trash pickup.
Go get that command again because I
forgot it.
Well, it's not getting merged without a
C.
Oh, you know what we should do?
We'll do this after, but we we should
finally do the thing to make the
rebuilds faster. Actually,
This is going into LLM. So, it's not
going to come out of the LLM. It's only
going into the LLM.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay. I misread that.
It's funny that it's like, "What do you
think of Gnome Brown?" Like I don't
I don't have opinions of like every
single person in AI, especially outside
of my exact niche.
You are not getting that answer out of
me.
This is also not relationship advice
stream. This is text stream.
Yeah. I'm doesn't mean doesn't mean I'm
answering that question.
Shark biting under sea cables.
Funny. All right. Have you got anything
here?
Okay.
Do you like Gary Marcus?
No. That guy is a grifter.
uh a charlatan
and generally an imbecile.
I have a really really fun thread though
from uh the first year of my PhD back
when I drank a lot. Uh, I was just
chilling and having a couple of beers as
you do in the evening, random night
during the week, and uh, the OpenAI
Rubik's Cube stuff finally came out and
Gary made like some dumb slide saying
like, "Oh, in expectation it does this,
but in reality it does that." And then I
like I made a meme like, you know,
poking fun at him and I posted that cuz
the Rubik's Cube work was really, really
good. And then I had like a stupid
debate where I just trolled him on
Twitter for two hours. It was awesome.
like, "Yeah, dude. Don't you have better
things to do than argue with a random uh
first year PhD student?" Guess not.
You can be my entertainment for the
evening then.
This line is replaced by the command
class variable.
That was really, really good work for
back then.
up for eval trained that's when I export
it and it sucks where should I look so
is it MLP LSTM Kong did you set the
number of parameters in the export to
the same as the number of parameters in
the load command and have it like the
load command specifies the number of
agents like the batch size and stuff
like that as well.
Yeah, deep minded open air I like that
was the golden era of RL right
pretty much
surrounding couple years.
All the layers are tested to exactly
match torch. So
if you have the observation types but
like if you have observation types wrong
though like sometimes you have like are
your observations unsigned chars or
something because like for some ends
right you have to copy observations into
the buffer manually there are examples
right I think like a snake or something
there's several examples
did not change do you have float obs
into actions.
Yeah, the robot hand's really good. Hey,
mechanics.
Oh, yeah. This is this is actually fine.
I see what this is doing. Cool.
I totally see what this is doing now.
Took me a second.
The way my brain works, I basically have
this internal meter for everyone where
like I assess whether you have like good
intentions. And if I think you have good
intentions, I will basically never be
mean to you. But as soon as I think you
do not have bad intentions, like all
bets are off.
Only Fish is great. Yep. Submitted fish
to Only Fish.
Prepared a competition. I'll give it a
shot. That doesn't overlap the start of
my PhD. Hrien, it's like a super easy
competition. You can do it in an
evening.
It's just like a um
it's like a really simple end and you
can tune some reward functions or you
can change the way it looks. It's a fun
competition because you're just trying
to make an agent that is fun to play
with.
Doresh tried some RL reward hacked him
in seconds. Yep, that was pretty funny.
Welcome to RL. And you're doing ultra
baby mode, RL.
I've not actually ever listened to uh
I've not listened to a single Door Cash
podcast, so I don't have anything
against him personally. My impression is
it's just like a general broader
audience thing and it's just like not my
cup of tea is like the big ideas and
whatever. He gets some good guests
but then obviously those guests are not
used to that uh like that kind of
environment.
The only fish wait the only fish
competition that thing. I mean this is
like a super basic look. It's really
simple. Here's a puffer. You can play
with the puffer. You can feed the puffer
and the puffer can see your mouse as
well. And it can see other puffers, too.
So,
if you want to submit me some puffers,
they go on there. Everybody can submit a
puffer.
I did not listen to that podcast. I did
listen to Sutton's talk though in person
at RLC. So
my impression generally is that um you
know Sutton really did set the
foundations of a lot of the like a lot
like a lot of the core machinery pretty
much all the core machinery is
established in his book. Um but nowadays
like the architectures he's describing
are too high level and like even if he's
right on his architectures the amount of
experimental validation and details
needed are like dramatically
dramatically outweigh the value of
highle ideas at this point.
I'm way more interested in his takes on
like you know specific mathematical
patches to credit assignment failings
and stuff like that.
I'd wait. I'd actually I'd love to
discuss that with him. Like my
bootstrapping article. I would love to
discuss that with him.
I could actually I wonder if he would
reply. He might reply.
He seemed like a just a generally like a
nice guy, too. He was really funny. They
had um at RLC they had the just the
shittiest cringe standup comedians ever
and they had a audience interaction
portion of it with him for a while and
he was way funnier than the comedians
which I thought was pretty great.
It's so funny how we have all these LLM
replies now. Like the [ __ ]
Can you make a puffer for the build
command?
Because I always forget it. Um,
I don't actually think you physically
can do that.
If you can figure if you can tell me
that it's possible and like then
if if it is possible to do that then
sure
but um
I don't think it because I think it's an
entry point right I think you have to
call a script in your project I don't
think you can call the setup.py pie. You
could maybe hack it in some roundabout
gross way, but I don't think that
there's like a a reasonable way of doing
it.
Oh,
before I do this next one though,
another bench set is required.
and the machine learning with Boltzman
machines. Yeah, I remember having to
work with Boltzman's machines. It was
the most obnoxious problem set I've ever
had to do at MIT, at least.
Uh, he didn't write a ren he did not
write a um
a proper renderer.
Wait, he did.
Oh,
he wrote the render. He wrote the
renderer in C, but he just wrote a print
renderer.
They don't seem useful for much. I guess
that's not true. I'm not going to tell
you that stats and uh physics well stats
and are BFs. I'm not going to tell you
they're not useful. I'm going to tell
you I don't have the background to see
how they could be useful. If you think
that there's a use for him, go ahead by
all means, right?
I'm going to give this guy some feedback
unless it looks AIE.
Let's see what this is.
So,
Nobody in hell formats the error. No
human does this, right?
There you go.
Am I porting M's Tuda? No, I'm going
through uh contributor PR's mechanics
today.
I got grilled for a couple weeks when I
started the drive truck.
Driverless truck backing up.
Mhm.
I got to go through uh some of your
recent stuff, man.
You've been doing this long enough that
you've probably gotten a lot better
since I've uh I've given you a review.
Oh, yeah. Should I
Is this ready for a merge convert?
actually. Hey, what would you what do
you want me to do with this? Because
it this is a big N.
Uh it's based on an N that like I helped
contribute and like it was already based
on a big N. Do you want me to like
review sections of this that you wrote
or what would you like me to do?
sections that were changed. Cool. Take a
quick look and then I will I'll go
through sections. Yeah.
build. Yeah, I can go through the PR.
I've actually seen that like several
times in SF. That's kind of hilarious if
you think about it.
Uh, hang on. Where's the stupid command?
I always forget the command.
Just
372.
Who?
That's a nice hand.
That's pretty cool.
Why is it Why are you like this?
Why is it like this?
Did you really make the end of that slow
that you need all those cores?
All right. So, let's just double this
48. Wait, how does that make any
bloodies? Hang on. What on earth did you
do?
What did you do?
12 *
48 * 64.
What is wrong with you?
Why have you done this? Explain
yourself.
Go on, explain yourself.
You're either going to provide me an
explanation of what you have done and
why you have done it, or you're going to
provide me an explanation of why this is
incredibly stupid.
That is the price of me continuing to
review this.
YOLO merch your first. Did I? H That's
my bad. I should have given you I think
it was that I wanted to get it into the
release and then I just never went back
to give you a proper review. I'm happy
to review that for you if you want since
I kind of owe you. I'd prefer it if you
could get me the cleaned like you could
like you basically can make a cleaned up
version of that with your newer stuff,
right? With the trailer things
now that will be worse. All right. Well,
then the price has been set.
Either explain why you have done this or
explain why this is stupid.
Okay, Tim, if you have a better name,
then go ahead. If you do not have a
better name than what?
So, you do not have a reason for doing
this and you do not know why this is
insane.
Is that what I'm hearing?
this is the total number of agents you
have. You have a BPTT horizon of 64
as well.
You have a batch size of 2.3 million,
which is about the batch size used in
Dota.
There's absolutely no reason for you to
have a batch size this big because
you're going to have to divide this by
the mini batch size
which is 32
768.
You're getting 72 gradient updates
per epoch. So you're getting after the
first update your data is all already a
little bit stale. you're getting 72
updates worth of staleness for
absolutely no reason because you've
already topped out the uh you've already
topped out the training speed way way
way before 36,000 environments. So
there's literally no reason in hell to
do this.
And you could have figured this out very
easily even without understanding any of
my shenanigans just by putting break
points and like looking at the sizes of
your tensors.
BPTT Horizon is well we use it for a
couple things in this case. So uh the
way Puffer does it we roll out each
environment so each agent for BPTT
Horizon steps. So everything gets
stepped every agent gets stepped 64
times. All right.
And then when you're doing your
training, right, the LSTM is going to
get this segment of 64 steps in a batch.
And that is how far backwards you're
being able to you are able to back prop.
In practice, in practice, we don't ever
use um a BPT horizon that's different
from the number of steps that you roll
out. But you technically could, right? I
could roll out for 256 steps and I could
only back propagate chunks of 64 to make
it faster. In practice, we don't ever do
that.
Let's see. Do I have to do basic
multiplication? 8 * 16 * 64
is 8192. That's better. That's like the
high end that you'd ever want to go.
All right. But I'm going to leave your
initial settings just for the hahas.
And I'm just going to make it work with
my machine.
You're up by 4x on the high end. Real
realistically like 8x.
Yeah, but the thing is you should have
like speed should be basically capped
out before then.
You should get very diminishing returns.
This thing has Perf.
I don't know why it's not logging this,
but
Well, then why is um that metric
different from the Perf metric?
AMA to explain these terms. Peru, that's
the stream.
The stream is you can always ask me
questions on [ __ ]
Yeah.
I mean, obviously, look, if I'm in the
middle of like uh if I'm in the middle
of like really deep cuda hell or
something, I might delay answering a
thing, but I'm not going to yell at you
like, "Why are you asking me a question
on this stream in which I am here?" So
that for the most part I can answer
questions.
I'm not mad at Kinvert for doing this
[ __ ] either, right? I'm giving him
feedback in strong enough terms that he
learns.
Wait another second. Yo, Kvert, did Bet
sign off on this [ __ ] On these bash
sizes.
H. Okay. Okay.
I was going to say I would hope he would
know by now.
I'm letting this train as a baseline by
the way
cuz it's almost done
But like the settings that you put
there, I would basically never use those
settings unless um if I were trying to
just do a absolute best case scenario
speed test, then I might do something
like that. Pretty much that's the only
thing.
Perfect deliver isn't looking good.
It actually got up to uh it got up to
one and then crashed. It looks unstable.
I didn't do anything that should mess
with your PF. I just changed the number
of cores, but I changed the number of
ends to compensate.
Thousands like perfect grip
thousands.
Uh, this looks like a 01 normalized
metric to me.
What's this? 4 * 16 64 * 64.
Is that 4096 or am I stupid?
Yes, that's correct. I'm not that
stupid. Okay, good. We do like this. We
do like that. And then we uh
we redo.
Oh, we want to do Eval.
Um,
I'm just going to do one more just to
see if this fixes it cuz that would be
really freaking funny.
Admittedly, you do actually lose um a
decent chunk of speed.
You have a big copy overhead, though.
And you're still at 2 million steps for
a 500k model.
I'm actually surprised you lose this
much. Um
that you lose this much to be honest. I
was expecting you to lose like maybe 10
20% speed at most.
That's so funny. This is actually a
thing, right?
Or is this like the most epic troll
ever?
There's something about them being um
Oh, wait. What's this?
what the heck is his
Twitter? There.
Wait, actually working in that one thing
sent in. Wait, what?
Oh, cool.
Uh, interesting. So,
this actually screws up Perf.
So, I'm guessing that you need to reweep
params convert.
Yeah, this at least needs a re-weap.
because first of all it's unstable
baseline then re sweep. Um I would try
like the thing that I did. I'm going to
kill this for now.
I'd try like 41664
something like that or Yeah, that's
probably good.
I forget if I gave you
Okay, good. Yeah.
Yeah, you should still have a box for
the open source stuff.
Whenever you just have something that
you don't like, whenever you don't have
a thing to do on trailer, just do like
41664.
Easy to remember. It's just the first
powers of four.
And then redo the sweep. See if you get
something stable.
W9.
Yeah. Yeah.
Of course. Right.
We do technically have like basic
security groups we can throw on for
work, but it has to be puffer work
and we do not position ourselves as like
a secure data whatever, right? We just
have basic [ __ ]
Okay. So, do you want me to look at do
you want me to look at N code
invert? Like, do you want me to look at
a couple chunks of N code or what's the
idea here?
See what else you can find, please.
Okay.
I can concur with this and it is not
enjoyable. Chicago is a terrible city.
It's basically on my no-fly list. I will
never return to this place. It is bad.
this thing.
Jesus.
Let's see what you got.
I will give you my best assessment.
That's this is what I will do for you
now. I will give you my best assessment
of your reward function. Okay.
This is presumably because you're
dividing by it at some point
velocity.
Let me look at this. I give you my
honest assessment before I get into
biases. All right.
angular
I don't know the units of angular
but okay
velocity magnitude is also known as
speed
pick.
Wait, the
um
what am I looking at? Let me see. Don't
tell me. Let me look first.
Reward max disc.
Yeah. Okay. Tell me what this is
supposed to be. I have no idea what this
is.
Like, tell me what this is. I don't I
have no idea what that is.
There needs to be a show fewer repost
from this dude thing.
Otherwise, my whole freaking timeline's
Elon reposts.
Can we get content based racks instead?
Be good.
Meant to give large rewards early
and small rewards later.
I'd be kind of suspicious of hacking
with some [ __ ] like this
window to earn the reward.
But the thing is
like getting rewards sooner rather than
later is baked into the algorithm
anyways, right? That's how credit
assignment works. That's the discount
factor.
Like if it's meandering around aimlessly
is because it doesn't know what to do
episodes
tick. Then why do you want to have lower
reward on later episodes? That's also
weird.
Early episodes lack standards. Late
episodes tighter standards.
This also seems weird.
The only thing that I could see maybe
convert is
the only thing that I could see would be
annealing. You could have something
where you enneal some of the reward
coefficients to zero over the course of
an episode. I would not over an episode
over training. So I would buy that. For
instance, you might have a reward
function with five components, right?
And one of those components is do you
win the game? And then the other ones
are like things related to winning the
game. And you could say that, hey, all
these reward components other than
winning are useful for training, but
they actually bias the policy. where we
want to use them early in training but
not by the end. And we're going to sort
out the coefficients with hyper tuning.
I could see something like that. I don't
know what this [ __ ] is though.
Um, proximity factor
1 minus disc over. Okay, so I don't know
about this weirdo function, right?
One over disc seems weird.
I typically
do my distance base rewards
convert as deltas. So if you want to
scale something, the thing that I would
suggest scaling would be um you take the
distance at the current time step,
subtract the distance from the previous
time step, right? you get the delta
towards the target or whatever and then
you scale that and that thing is way
better behaved
because continuous rewards that have
like a drifting baseline are really
jank.
I can Discord
um if my freaking Discord works. They
broke a lot of the sound codecs in the
latest update.
Hey.
Yeah. How's it going?
Unmute desktop. Let me Hang on. Let me
get the desktop audio to work.
[Music]
Properties.
How's this thing?
say something.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yeah, there we go. All right, cool. Your
audio is going to be on stream as well.
>> Yeah, it's good.
>> Okay, so
what do you have for me?
>> Great. So, um, basically the thinking
with these uh, rewards and and I agree
with what you're saying. So I was
rewarding the accuracy and that that is
what you would need early on. Later on I
can see what you mean of instead of
rewarding the accuracy itself later on
you're rewarding specifically the
perfect delivery is my end metric
>> that I want it to maximize on.
>> Um
>> but I don't even know if the task is
that hard that you need to do that.
>> That's like some [ __ ] I would do to
solve neural MMO 3.
>> Maybe.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yep. No, I agree that your
neurommo 3 is harder than this, right?
Um, but also like a I'm new and b I
hacked this together in two weeks.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
>> what I'm saying is like I don't think
that your default should be to engineer
crazy complicated rewards because like
you should have a pretty strong prior
belief that like about this problem is
about this hard and this is about the
amount of reward NJ should have to do,
right?
Like if you tell me Dota or Pokemon or
whatever, if you tell me these problems
need a ton of reward, I'll be like,
"Okay." But if you tell me that a
variant of drone m needs crazy reward,
then I'm going to be a little more
confused. If you tell me that this has
like two or three components with tuned
coefficients that are like, you know, a
distance reward, a grabbing reward, and
like maybe one other thing, then I'll be
then I'll I'd believe that, right?
>> Yep.
That's like how I think about stuff and
how I'd encourage you to think about
some stuff. So having a proximity thing
is good. I would do it in terms of
deltas. Delta rewards are generally
better.
>> You know what I mean? Does have I made
it clear what I mean by deltas.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You're just subtracting the
two and instead of doing this one over
something and making it this nonlinear,
it's just like, hey, you're literally 5
meters away.
>> Um,
>> you can make it nonlinear if you want to
be honest. is you could even make it
nonlinear is the thing but like doing it
based on deltas instead of based on
absolute position is way easier to
learn.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> Because you don't end up having this
like you don't end up with a uh a
trajectory level like baseline that
you're trying to optimize implicit. It's
like way easier to learn.
>> Yep. Um another thing that kind of drove
some of these equations because I was
just throwing stuff at the wall. If you
scroll down a little, you'll see that I
would create a reward function here,
like reward distance and proximity
reward, stability reward, and then
towards the bottom of this function, I
multiply them by a constant, and then I
swept that constant.
>> Yep, that's correct.
>> So, like a W position.
>> So, the weight.
>> Yeah. So, I swept the weight of
position, weight of velocity, the weight
of these different things, and it would
decide which these signals were useful
and not.
>> And if I ran one and it's like, hey, I'm
multiplying this by zero. I'm like,
well, I just accidentally made a crappy
metric and so I'm going to rewrite it.
And I'm trying to get them all to be
approximately a 1.0 saying, hey, I
actually used this to learn
>> to because in the sweeps I was
maximizing perfect delivery.
>> Um,
>> so you don't need them to be all 1.0.
>> Uh, but if it if it optimizes to zero,
then that's bad. If you see if you get
something where like all the best runs
are 0.05
and like definitely not zero, but 0.05,
05. It could be that it's just a way
more frequent reward, right? I've seen
that happen before. So, don't expect
them to all be on the same magnitude,
but just look for like significant
values because you can just you can
basically make a plot, right? That is
reward component versus uh performance
and n like reward weight versus
performance and n. And if you see
something that looks like,
let me just make this point.
So if you see something that looks like
like this where you have zero 0.05
0.1 right if you see something where you
have like
right and like you have you're not going
to get a line like this. You're going to
get like points but maybe you have like
points like this.
If it looks like this then it's still
it's still a good reward signal. You see
what I mean? Yep. Yep.
>> Because like it doesn't matter that it's
not one. It matters that having this is
way better than not having it.
>> That makes sense.
>> So always look for this.
>> Okay. Um Yeah, that makes sense. Yep.
>> Okay. And let me see what else do we
have here. You got
>> Yeah. Rightly or wrongly, that was my
thinking when I was rushing through
this.
There's a really fun um section of the
Dota paper where the Dota team was
rushing through tuning rewards uh and
hyperparameters before the big
competition that they lost before they
beat the full game. And they actually
put in the paper like the values of
their learning rate over time and it's
like this insane squiggly graph and it
was and they basically wrote TLDDR
humans are bad at tuning
hyperparameters. Don't do this manually
under pressure.
Yeah.
>> Okay. So, you got a position reward. So,
it's the weirdly weighted thing, but the
thing itself is fine, right? Like having
a distance reward is fine. Having a
velocity reward is also fine.
>> Yep.
Yeah. The goal was generally to simulate
like a pip
So the approach was generally to say
your velocity is towards the target
instead of away.
>> Okay. Um
>> these are all reasonable things. I think
you basically you wrote so you wrote
complicated versions of reasonable
things,
>> right?
>> Yeah. That that could very well be. Yep.
>> And it's really difficult to think about
this because I don't know what exp you
know like I don't know what the hell
this translates to. So I would have you
probably did start with stuff simp like
simpler stuff but you probably didn't
start with the right simpler stuff
because you didn't do delta based
things. So for continual rewards
>> I started I started with pure deltas and
it wasn't working and it could have been
because again it was a hackathon. Um it
could have been that I did it wrong and
then I'm like well this isn't enough so
I'm going to make it more complicated.
Yeah that uh that could have been the
wrong approach.
>> It's possible. I generally would heir on
the side of
like define your five components or
whatever this is, right? Make sure
they're normalized to reasonable ranges.
Um,
you know, make sure they're normalized.
There there can be a thing where like,
you know, I have one end where I have
like a fine grain distance and a like a
coarse distance if the final thing like
the precision is really important. I
think I did that on the drone end. Stuff
like that can happen, but for the most
part, it's kind of just you define some
components. You make sure that the way
the reward is set up is saying it's
going to be delta based. If it's like
this, sparse rewards are even simpler,
right? And then you sweep the weights.
>> Yep. Yep. Um and then Yeah. So, for
example, in the uh the compute
observations, there's both a normalized
like for the whole map, you're negative
one to one for the whole map
>> and then there's another where it's
literally you're within one meter of the
box and now I'm giving you a float of
you're you're 3 meters away. Um because
to pick up the boxes, we needed like
five centimeter accuracy to pick up the
boxes.
>> Yeah, having a fine grain thing is kind
of reasonable.
>> The only thing you have to make sure
though when you do a fine grain thing
with deltas is they have to sum to zero,
right? So you can't just jitter back and
forth and get a positive sum reward.
>> No. So you have to make sure that when
you're your scaling function, okay, if I
go from like point, if I go from here
and I get closer and then I step back
and then I go closer, it has to sum to
zero. So like there can't be any way
that you can just jitter near the target
and farm reward.
>> Yeah, that's what I had. I had that at
first.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So that's what happens when you get if
you do absolute rewards, right? It's
just going to hang around the target and
never finish the episode. That's another
thing that delta solve. Roboticists
actually typically they do it wrong
where they use absolute rewards and that
they have a wrong advantage function
that cancels out that first error.
>> Yep.
>> So
running into that too just intentionally
jitter. Yep.
>> Yep. That's why they do it. That's why
they do it. They're farm and reward.
And then six components.
I said five. Six is fine. It's about
like we'd expect hover bonus. Yeah, this
is all. So, pretty much you had you had
roughly uh the right idea on all these
things. The execution is more
complicated than I I can basically
guarantee you there is a simpler version
of this that does at least as well. I
can't guarantee you that my exact
version works perfectly. Like there
might be some like some significant
tweaks that you need, right? like
especially for the fine grain stuff, but
mostly that should be it.
>> Okay,
>> any other questions on this chunk?
>> Um, that's kind of the the main thing
really. Um,
>> about the best thing for you to take
away. You've gotten two good pieces of
information, right? The rewards thing
and then the uh the train params thing.
Anything else you'd like me to take a
quick look at for now? Because if not,
I'm going to let you like revise this
and then submit the end with a nice
train model. We'll get on the site.
>> Yeah. Um, so let me think. I mean, the
compute rewards. So that was a somewhat
interesting one where I had different
ways of training and I would zero some
out and add in and then I added in one
reward to say whether or not this was um
the uh drone pick and place. And so I
had like a one and a zero that I would
throw in. And I think that's another
one, by the way, that I wanted to fix
and didn't have time was getting rid of
that um observation because basically
what I did is
>> this was at first built within your full
drone swarm and then within that you
choose a task. There were like eight
tasks.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> and then to prune this down, I got rid
of all the tasks and just have the one
task.
>> Um but I didn't get rid of that in the
observations. So I knew that this wasn't
done done. Um,
>> having one redundant observation that's
like consistent is not bad.
>> Okay.
>> It's not like, oh, because you give it
an extra zero,
>> it's just like a tiny bit of code blow.
It's not a big idea. Like not a big
deal.
>> Yep. Okay, that makes sense. Um, yeah.
Was there any Let me see. Uh, there's
anything else that really stands out.
So, the drone swarm. Um so in theh
the uh yeah the compute observations the
reward was kind of the big one. Um
resetting delivery is kind of
straightforward. It randomized things
like when it picks up it'll randomize
the bump that the drone feels from
grabbing the box. Um and then updating
the grip physics um the reset step. It's
pretty I think straightforward. The the
step was interesting. I trained it. If
you want to briefly look I gave it
phases. Um, and so if you search for uh
phase space one um within the file,
you'll So basically the first goal
>> there two. Yeah, it's going to be down
inside of uh inside of step. Let's let's
see if it's Cstep or not. Yeah, in Cstep
there. So you got phase one, phase two,
phase three.
>> Um so somewhat different structures for
depending on whether you're going above
the box, then descending down straight
to it. you've grabbed the box, now
you're going to go and deliver. And then
you hover slowly downwards to drop off.
Um, and so this was uh basically doing
different forms of reward hacking. And
so I had to restrict it. And so for
example, um,
>> the the grip is like the the constant
um, and the box is a constant. So
basically at first I would train it
where the box is at like a zero mass and
you can easily grab it and then you can
deliver, you can get rewards. And then
over time I scale it up to 1.0 0 where
you're picking up the full mass of the
box, for example.
>> This is reasonable. It It is probably
contributing to the instability somehow.
The fact that this is just done over the
episode instead of based on Perf.
>> I think that if you sweep hypers, it
will probably still work. But like the
fact that if it just if for whatever
reason it starts screwing up like the
problem doesn't get any easier.
>> Yep.
>> So be aware of that. But I having this
phase type stuff is generally
reasonable. And you see similar stuff in
robotics code. It's just that they write
everything in shitty vector logic
because they cannot write you know
beautiful C.
>> Yep. Yep. And yeah, the only other big
thing to to cover because I know I've
still got stuff to change would be um
you know I have different ways I could
do this in because we were the whole
point was to port this into Isaac SIM
and win a competition in Isaac Sim. Um,
and so we were thinking if we want to
have the complexity in puffer or an
Isaac sim.
>> So what I could have done is had a point
that I control an Isaac sim and say,
"Hey drone, just follow this point." And
then an Isaac sim, I put it over the
box. I lower it down to the box. The
drone picks up and it's always following
that point. Instead, I created something
called, and you see it there, the hidden
position. Mhm.
>> Um, so instead what I did is I gave the
observations of the box itself, but then
I I gave a hidden reward and it's
getting the reward, but it doesn't know
why. So I have that if you run the eval,
you'll see the yellow dot that's over
top of the box.
>> That's what that is right there.
>> Um, and then I slowly lower the dot and
I do that inside a puffer li. Um,
>> so you don't have to do it in
>> Yeah. and the drone just learns there's
the box and I know the pattern is to
hover down slow and trying to train it
that way. So it was a layer of
complexity.
>> Um and I found it it worked but that
could be another uh
>> makes it a little more upper side.
>> Cool. So when do I have um apparently
the post office here burned down and I
no longer get two-day Amazon delivery.
So when can I have some of these drones
deployed to my area?
>> Right.
Um, yeah. I actually got one of them.
They're 65s, so it could be pick up big
enough to pick up a ant or something.
>> An ant. Yeah. I sent Sam and Finn a
slightly better drone. Uh, and they've
been posting some cool videos.
>> They say they're getting the neural net
in it soon.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I'm excited to do that. I'm
looking at the the drone forge
potentially to do it to communicate back
and forth. Um, but yeah, right now I'm
on things. So,
>> I have a whole bunch of space to fly
drones out here if we need to test
anything as well.
>> Well, I want to make I I want to make
them help with a farm, like picking up
chicken feed buckets and chicken picking
up five gallon buckets of water. It's
going to take a pretty big drone.
>> Yeah.
>> Um or at least chasing around foxes and
stuff so they don't get the hens, you
know. Yeah,
>> that's tough. Well, it's actually the
foxes are easy enough to uh to keep out.
It's the freaking snakes. Right.
>> The snakes that you have to those things
are awful.
>> Anything. Yeah.
>> Uh let's see.
>> Honestly, like
it'd be cool if you could just have a
drone follow you around. Like that'd be
an easy and a much easier thing to start
with.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The easy one would be like,
you know, wear a a very red hat or
something like that and it just picks
up. So the computer vision part's very
easy.
>> Um
>> Yeah. They just wear you just wear a red
hat and then the drone follows you. If
it just like follows you at like a
reasonable like consistent distance,
that'd be really cool.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Can I just like instead of having a Can
I just walk my drone?
>> Get a little leash on it.
>> Spy, you do nothing but yap. Shut up.
We've been going through uh Kvert's code
here.
>> This is code. Look, there's code on the
screen
>> if you wanted to pay attention a lot to
learn.
>> All right.
Yeah. All right. Anything else to look
at?
>> Uh, no. Those are the main things.
>> Cool. So, clean up a little bit. You
don't have to go redo rewards or
anything. You've already done this
project. Just like see if you can get a
stable because you got some cool
policies, right? So, can you just get a
stable thing out of if you can just get
a stable thing out of the sweep, I think
we can merge it. And um,
>> yep. Make sure that there is a good uh
zero one scaled perf metric is the other
thing.
>> If you want perfect deliver whatever to
be the metric that's fine but just make
sure whatever it is that the thing that
you're storing in perf as the metric is
a clean 0ero to1 scaled thing because
for constellation in the new project
we're trying to have everything that we
use have a clean 0ero to one PF and then
we can put everything nicely on the same
plot and we can very cleanly control it.
>> Gotcha. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. I'll add that
to the list.
>> And does this have
does this have um
Oh, yeah. You do have a policy and see.
Cool.
That's fine.
All right.
Well, thank you. If that's all I will uh
I'm going to get back to PRS.
>> Sounds good. All right. Thanks a lot.
See you. See you.
Fun
All right, let me use the restroom real
quick. Get another set in and then we
will continue on PRs.
his favorite ab exercise is very, very
good.
Kung's two,
and Eton is here as well.
Eton, are you in the chat?
Two of Eton's and M's actually.
We got Overcooked,
got Tetris.
Lots of stuff.
Y
There's so many freaking
so many PRs.
Want to get that export
that export.
Tetris first. I want to get that export.
Wait, when you say Tetris first, you
want me to look at Tetris or what do you
want me to do?
This thing.
This forget this command.
Do not remember this command.
Train checkpoint is in a Wanda B.
Okay.
Is this it?
Wait, because this is this is still
playing. I would think it would not play
anymore if you uh Oh, I see. It doesn't
exactly play anymore. It plays badly
now, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Very good. That looks like a nice
policy.
Holy moly.
Three billion steps.
Dude, that's kind of cool.
I'm really surprised. Is this after a
sweep as well?
surprised you can get this per stable
baselines. PO definitely doesn't.
Welcome to Puffer. Uh Kyouong has
trained this for billions of steps as
well.
Stable baselines doesn't do that. Stable
baselines is slow.
Oh man, why am I this tired? Why am I
this tired?
Young, this model does not look like
it's doing particularly good.
Is it like a thousand IQ secretly?
No, it just it just died.
Is it just like Hang on. Is it better
now?
Thought I saw a die when the screen
cleared before.
Trained to do garbage lines.
Like why is it why is it playing like
this?
That's not a level That's not level 20.
On the graph, it says this level 20
agent. No,
You've seen the other stuff we've done
in Puffer.
Yeah, but the you know it's the big
fish.
If this is provably NP hard or some
[ __ ] No, it can't be.
If it's NP hard, then like I need to
take a second thought about my opinions
of theoretical computer scientists
and whether that distinction actually
matters. But there's no way
Kind of cool. It's not a perfect agent
though. Like it still does not
understand like
Yeah. Okay. So, it doesn't understand
that uh it's it's screwing itself over
by
uh by leaving these gaps.
God damn it. The controls are screwing
me.
Try that again.
Yeah. Like why would it do this from the
start, right?
Yep. Okay. Well, I'm sort of hamstrung
by the controls a little bit, but it's a
good agent.
Let's
Yeah. So the policy that we just loaded
is no good, right?
have any custom net at all.
same freaking code.
Trying to think if we want to do
I mean we do have a we do have a
surefire way to test this type of thing.
It's just very annoying.
like we have um
you know we have all the layers with
Python bindings that we can test one for
one.
Python deck size is hardcoded and used
in gym box. What do you mean?
Uh actually
this is interesting because this is not
getting used.
There's no deck size in here, right? So
it's not getting used.
well it affects the I checked that the
shapes are the same,
right? So this deck size has to match
because the shapes are currently the
same even though this is not getting
used. So they should not be here but um
the shapes are the him.
Unless something got changed in the
LSTM, but I doubt that, All right.
I'm just wondering is it possible a
change got merged in that breaks our
policy exporter? I would doubt it,
right?
No, we have gallos. I was trying to see
if we messed up with the yellows not
being there, but we are using gallows.
And I tried this as well for uh the
only fish thing as well.
greater than UV. Built makes your M code
super slow.
So if you like to be if you like slow
snake, use kind of.
We're merging PRs actually. We're
attempting to
I'm going to try this for a few more
minutes and then Kung, you might have to
um
you might have to run a little test on
this
I'll show you how to do it.
I'm trying to figure out if I can avoid
that. It would be way better if we just
had this work and be done.
Okay. I want to go look at the uh the
other PR. So, Kyouong, this is the way
you test uh nets that are being buggy.
I hope this is not a puffer bug. Um it
make me sad. But
we have this test puffer net thing in
here.
So basically what you can do
um
we have a little bit of an example here
sort of
but you can basically call each of these
layers.
So you can just like slice off the first
chunk of your network in PyTorch and
then you can just test the outputs
versus the uh the ones in C because we
have bindings for all the different
functions
and then you'll basically are guaranteed
that you have exactly the same thing in
both.
It's sort of annoying, but it actually
like it prevents you from just staring
at code like at staring at code and not
knowing why. Like here's the LSTM test
for instance, right? And you can just
like check the whole LSTM at once.
I do want to get your um your other big
PR in cuz the protein PR is a really big
one, right?
This is looking good though. This is
looking very good.
ruins the high cost
long tail
updates to puff in and puff RL
train stops early.
Loss becomes nan.
No model upload
Got our Tetris config
code review streams. Yeah,
I do them once in a while.
I'd like to do a more, but like the
thing that's tough, right, is
ultimately somebody has to do the like
the core puffer improvements
for the next updates, right? So if
anybody wants to step up and help with
like crazy ass CUDA bugs and you know
compile shenanigans and all that hard
optim stuff, if anybody wants to
actually help on that stuff, I will be
more than happy to spend more time on
community stuff. Like basically the
reason I have no time is because I still
have to be the one doing the uh
like all that stuff at the moment
and I still am trying to get out like
two major updates roughly a year.
This was another bug. I caught this in
my multi sweep. This is a bad one. Good
fix.
Chinese bounty model.
Um,
do you think that would work?
I'd have to be a lot more I'd have to be
a lot more organized and formal
about um about my work process, I think.
Right. Like it's possible. I'd have to
be a lot more formal about my work
process.
Uh, is all
Oh, I'm I'm totally fine like putting
money on stuff. Like Puffer has enough
revenue now that like putting a few
hundred buck bounties on things that
save time is totally chill.
So, I guess here's the here's the
question for you guys. And I think you
know who would be really good at
figuring this out? Kyouong. Kyouung is
the most ridiculously organized person
I've ever met. Um,
the thing that I have that I tend to do
is I tend to like in the process of
investigating a major new thing, I tend
to just shred the code.
And I can't really just hand people
here's shredded code fix please. Right.
I've tried many many times to like see
if I could be more organized and it's
just not me.
It's just not
M's are cool.
Well, I mean, I tried to do a little of
this with the guide, Tim, right? Like
the RL guide I have intersperses
the research materials.
You know, maybe we'll maybe I'll try
that tomorrow, right?
Maybe I will
maybe what I'll do is I'll clean up the
40 branch
and
Yeah, but Tim like I have to put some
guidel like the thing is you have to be
pretty precise about all of it.
I little things are helpful. The bigger
things are the really helpful stuff like
things like this here. This saves me
days, right?
Like this thing here saves me days.
Probably more than days.
This could be like a all week project
depending on the week.
Like the thing that I have in mind right
now, okay, is the torch compile
shenanigans
that I just do not know how to do deal
with. Um,
I would very very happily pay, you know,
500 bucks to have somebody figure out
how to make uh torch compile play nice
and like compile fast for our whole
train loop with LSTMs
like very easily.
You're going to have to send Kung a cake
then
cuz I can't and eat it cuz I can't send
it really.
Well, if this PR works, dinner's
definitely on me next time, and it'll be
something better than the F place.
Get this free drone if you're fast
enough.
Ooh,
talk to me about this, Kung.
Talk to me about this.
So, you're right that having a while
loop can technically hang.
Um,
you cannot get you can end up with uh
runs that do not report stats back
70,000ish.
Oh,
so that means it's like never losing.
Did it hang forever ever though?
It could literally just be that it's not
losing.
And if you got 70,000 on 2048, I want
that policy because that's nuts.
You actually probably just kind of
smoked it with these new sweeps, huh?
How does Kyouung know what to do the
core algorithm? Een Kung contributed to
Puffer and worked with me for like what,
two years,
Trainer has stats. Mean and log can
handle it.
But Kyouong, what happens when you have
really long episodes, right, and this
post eval doesn't return a score?
Yeah, three years now counting like the
stuff from the last year. The last year
you've had other stuff to work on.
Trying to think how long ago the
animation stuff was. The animation stuff
a year ago.
I don't know. It's been a crazy couple
of years for me, honestly.
I am somewhat concerned that this is
going to break my new constellation
stuff, but I'll tell you what, if it
does, all I have to do is add a couple
lines to the pre-processing,
so it's not terrible.
While I less than 32
or not stats,
Let's just say here, Kyouung, I would I
think that we should do something
slightly more intelligent than this. And
this is actually going to affect sweeps
on some M's. Okay?
Because this is going to affect the
quality of the evaluation you get for
that last uh that final point.
Especially the M's where you have to set
down sampling off because uh you know
the curve moves too fast. This can
affect things.
But I will keep this like you have it
for now because yeah can be annoying and
while loops are generally bad.
I think I'm going to merge this as well.
I don't really like making it a call
back like this.
I think I'd just make it a bool and then
just have this line be whatever it is
for typing.
Wait, what do you mean you added ABC for
typing?
Explain.
I generally do not like ABC or Python's
type system at all.
Let sweep know and handle aborted
trainings. If training was aborted, drop
the last point.
Okay.
Train function sig.
I absolutely hate Python's typing
system.
I think it just adds bloat and it
doesn't really do anything for you.
And like you don't even need it in this
case because there's no reason to pass a
callable here.
Okay, so we have
let's get to this GP GPI torch.
Let's just take a look at this project.
I just want to see if it's like one of
those obnoxious ones.
[ __ ] you, Jack typing. But other than
that, that's fine.
Jacks,
that's fine.
And it's written in torch anyways.
And then you have your tests.
Very nice.
I'm going to start using this. Man, this
is nice. This actually works the way uh
it should. Like this is nice.
I actually I remember that I took um
I took the thing off the GPU before
because it was slower on GPU with um
Pyro.
Okay.
And you wrote some nice tests. Good job.
sweep is um honestly contribution to
sweep like this is a really really major
one. Sweeps are so incredibly important.
So for those watching who are like how
do I carve out a little area that I can
do a pretty major contribution stuff
like this.
Yeah, seeing the amount of work. Well,
let's see the uh the main implementation
cuz so far this looks like this would be
this looks like a very substantial
amount of work even if I were uh doing
it.
What on earth is this?
I guess I'll see
what time is it also. Okay, I got 40
minutes before dinner
and then after dinner I got to fix my
mic because I have u that crazy podcast
that Bet set
and I got to get myself into a better
mood for that. When I'm like when I'm
just like generally kind of tired, I get
really flippant.
just get really flippant.
Listening to the Dresden files like
constantly during all my exercise
probably has not helped with that.
if not observations. Wait, let me let me
make sure I'm doing this here.
Okay, I actually have to read this when
wake up because this is a very like this
is very very important. Default tensor
DT type.
But wait, doesn't this is this not going
to make all of our training 64-bit?
this one's really rough, man.
This one's saying you don't actually
like take driving for instance. We have
the driving sim where like you actually
really care about.999
versus.99,
right?
Like usually when you have stuff that's
01 scaled like that, it's win rate. And
win rate of 99 versus 999 is a big
difference.
if I put a flag to turn on off, it will
work for most Ms.
Let me think.
You want a stable solve, don't you?
Like even for stuff like breakout, one
of the things that annoys me about um
sweeps is like we don't really have a
good way to distinguish
uh points that when you run it like you
mostly get something around 95% solve
versus you always consistently will get
a full solve
It gives me good leads, but it's not
good leads, right? Like
you basically you want the sweep is
supposed to find you the best solve. No.
it depends. E10. If you just solve the
whole thing in your sweep, then you
don't need to, right? And ideally,
that's what we'd like to eventually have
it be, right? That your sweep just
solves it for you.
And like actually the way protein is
supposed to work, right, is protein is
only supposed to spend more compute when
it's doing better. So you should be able
to technically just give protein really
big compute limits. Uh that doesn't work
as well as it should in practice
sometimes, but that's the goal.
This is a linear and a matern. This is
the same kernel, right?
Uh, quick couple gotchas. So, Kyouong,
did you do did you set the cost mean the
way I did it in old protein?
like the cost me into one or whatever it
was.
I remember that. So you can set the mean
function for a kernel, right? And I
remember I had one of the the kernels
set to the mean to one.
It makes a difference in recommendations
because it basically
Oh, chat. Yeah, chat's slow on Twitch on
X.
break.
needs at least a warning.
Are we still doing random samples? cuz I
had gotten rid of random samples in my
um
I'd gotten rid of random samples before.
30 is fine. Only six. I see. So you have
it that way.
This is very different.
You're using time steps as cost.
That's like a completely different
optimization problem.
Like this should give you massively
different results.
The length of random runs.
Oh,
I hear you that it's not what it seems
to be. I just don't want to hear any
more complaints about end numms, deck
numms. If you're going to do this
noble
the hell
log normal prior There.
This is the same as is this the same as
we had before? Cuz I remember I took the
params from carbs which took them from
Hebo
Chung, you should really run some like
ablations on this stuff and make a blog
post cuz this is a lot of good work.
Provided all this new stuff is actually
use like useful in some way. This is a
lot of very good work.
This similar to Optuna, Optuna gives you
uh algorithm implementations for a bunch
of like different methods. This is so
this here is the method based on my own
research which is based on carbs and
then which Kyouung has now gone and made
a ton of improvements to that are sort
of it seems like most of the
improvements are sort of around the main
algorithm. They're sort of general
purpose things for the most part
like filtering and such. I guess some of
them are like Purto specific specific to
Purto methods like this,
but I don't see anything here that's
like Well, we'll see see what else. This
could definitely make a big difference
though. Big big difference.
Well, it's not the same as protein
exactly, right? You've made a heck of a
lot of improvements.
Well, I guess it depends how you look at
it, right? Because I guess the
filtering, you could look at the
filtering as just making it faster
because there are fewer points, so you
can do more runs without it slowing
down.
What are the main differences pruning in
the GP with what? the main differences
between protein and what came before or
what what's
Young has made a lot of changes. So, he
changed it from pyro to a GPI torch. Um,
it looks like he's done a lot of
filtering operations to cut out
redundant points. It looks like he's
added early stopping to filter bad runs.
Increased numerical spilled.
Interesting.
I will say it's kind of sketchy though
that you need to do that.
But wait, I don't understand.
How is this supposed to do anything?
Because you don't have any samples to
have fit a cost model yet, right?
Like how is this supposed to rely on the
cost if you have not really fit a cost
model?
You start from seed.
What do you mean you start from seed?
Oh, like the one the one good run or
what?
Yeah, but is that really going to be
enough? I guess you could say that maybe
that's enough to fit a little bit of a
cost model. I don't know.
I want to prevent random runs.
I see.
You could technically have it give it a
budget as well, Chong. You know, one
thing we could move towards, I don't say
you shouldn't do this now, but we could
have it so that the um the algorithm
gives you a hyper pram set and a cost
budget, right? So that if you exceed the
cost budget, it just stops early.
got to go pick up kids. No worries.
I'll look through and if there's
anything else, um I think I'll probably
just be able to merge it unless I have
any other questions and we'll chat more
about it later.
Thank you very much.
There's all my original code.
Observe.
Okay. Moderately annoying, but this is
fine.
Yeah, this is good.
Cool.
I very much like this.
KD tree is just used for pruning uh
pruning bad values.
I'm glad to have gotten this merged in
today.
totally Forgot about this thing.
Save my 20 bucks.
Here's a restroom real quick. We'll get
a a quick sweep going. I'll answer a
couple questions and I'm going to go for
dinner.
Right back.
Waddler.
Lynald.
Waddler. Lindig.
The heck is that?
Any burning questions, anybody? Oh,
let's get B's uh puffer onto the website
real quick. That'll be funny.
All right.
The bottom feeding puff.
I want my end beaten improved. I can
take a quick look, but I got to go for
dinner pretty soon. Let me copy this
over. One sec.
All right, that is um that is the puffer
pushed.
He will be on the website at OnlyFish in
just a few moments.
Go take a look at your PR.
Oh yeah, and for everybody watching
here, this is all open source stuff. Um,
and it's all on puffer.ai. So if you
want to get involved, start GitHub helps
me out a ton. It's free. Uh, Discord,
it's where to be if you want to be in
dev and all my stuff is on X. You can
follow me there as well. All helps me
out.
Oh, this might be screwing it up if it
doesn't know which is which.
Wait, this is 4096 M. And then
I forget what our defaults are.
Okay, that's high, but it's fine. Like,
that's actually reasonable enough.
that is a very very high gamma you found
there my friend.
Uh,
that's a pretty like surprisingly low
learning rate. Oh, actually, no, it's
not. It's fine.
That's fine. Never mind. I read it
wrong.
Always dangerous to be doing um
this type of shenanigans, but I see you
wanted to add some stuff. Okay.
Do you have curves?
Those curves
You probably don't need three encode
layers, but okay.
And then I guess this is one hotted. If
this is one hotted, it's fine.
How many prams is your net?
I didn't know what to do in the neural
net.
Nothing work.
Usually you don't have to go crazy in
the neural net.
I would like some curves for this
6 mil train is good. I'm going have to
go to dinner in a minute, but let me see
if I find you anything.
Oh,
I am starving as well.
Other than the two space code habit
seems quite clean.
I guess. Are these just fully random
puzzles?
Have you tried Yeah, link me w in
Discord. Have you tried letting it go
take multiple passes over the end to
like adjust stuff?
in general.
Wait,
is it in Where is the uh
Oh, I got to go to dinner. I will be
possibly back after. I might have some
client work to do, though. Thanks,
folks. I got to.